yeah welcome to this video on it sir due
to this feed or kind of setup there's
also g4 here right now can let's play
play aggressively at least fifth it
looks aggressive from the surface it's
not sure that it's actually so great
okay but what does White's do now just
h3 probably protecting the center should
G 292 yeah I don't want b-52 happen
yeah just when I just had a plan I had
planned to play a for but ok it takes it
it takes a 5 is excellent from white
right there he not steak yeah this this
is some big edge for white the to Bishop
cm in an open position and it's the D
file also just a pile up on the default
queen d success is simple but good
yeah cannot he cannot really am exchange
um yeah but he doesn't really have a
great square for the night so I can
probably just a double
yep setting up the pin yeah did you get
out of the default
well yeah I cannot move much it's a very
passive hmm
95 really
what if i take take on your form yeah
but ok can take on e for us and then
take be too not sure
mm yeah not sure how to continue the
spin is really annoying
yeah I probably didn't play this the
best possible way after he takes a five
white is strategically almost winning
and this isn't so clear
check
you can actually take I cannot create
yeah I wanted to threaten see for him
but for a moment I thought you could
take any way jump intending some
desperado thing on you three yeah I need
to do this anyway ok so how to do this
probably here
I need to get the porn at three
k i'm not sure what you should do now
look t5 threatening queena 3 and d 6
what Jesus Christ what what a game what
are you doing to me takes
what don't get it ok takes on age three
maybe this is in effect working Queen f2
I can you have to Queen edge to King you
one if to put Mookie aid or something
okay I think it's very working check
unbelievable I mean this is keeping some
advantage I think because Lucas is just
too it stuck here but still amazing
at least I'm not hopelessly behind on
the clock okay Rukia at the end should
be should be a rock up end game for
three pawns admittedly check gathered
upon promotes
black resigns Wow but what the heck look
F to just play drew gave two and King f2
is a draw okay and this is chad to
computer thing since this is too risky
and gives black an edge you will see 5
what the heck this is what I cannot
believe that yeah absolutely no I don't
think black can be better against the
pawn d7 he wants to play Quincy 725
maybe but how to believe but what really
interests me is how on earth did this
become a game again I already played
this like a [ __ ] this is just this
position is strategically winning for
white I only need to play it played in
some some decent way it's two bishops
they're both excellently placed it's
full of weaknesses and I'm even quicker
on the D file so why am I not winning
this game quickly huh now the computer
is unimpressed 0.2 but i don't believe
that twin 83 years the comp
recommendation yeah I like that actually
I'm getting out of the D file and try to
regroup regroup properly somehow this
way it wasn't it wasn't all that great
here mr. miss bishop b6 there should be
six that's good
this kind of idea yeah complicated stuff
yeah thanks for watching